i think it'd be really interesting to
kind of talk about the type of real
estate that you guys buy um and my
understanding is that there's really
kind of two different types uh kind of
this class b uh commercial real estate
and then i think you also do some self
storage but i may be wrong on that so
like talk us through just kind of the
the various types of real estate you
could purchase and why you're so focused
on the class b stuff
yeah
it's an honor to be on the show we we
buy class b industrial and so there's
class a and there's class b and we
really don't do any self storage but
class a is um
the best way you can think about it is
it's the newer built stuff
this is the stuff that is uh that
amazon's going into that's a million
square feet that the large ecommerce
businesses and the large companies are
taking
large clear heights these are huge
buildings that are being developed
class b
is stuff that was built in the 60s 70s
80s 90s
and by nature of when it was built one
we know it's older but two these are the
buildings that are in the middle of the
city when they were being built they
used to be on the outskirts of the city
but now that we're you know 30 40 50
years later this is in the middle of
these cities and and provide an
incredible service to these mature
neighborhoods around them so i can start
like that's a good foundation for what
denominates class a versus class b
got it so when we think about this why
is class b so attractive to you when
people hear that oh class a that's where
the amazons and like all these
businesses are going million square feet
like that's incredible what is it about
the class b inside of these uh kind of
city or urban areas that uh makes it
such a great opportunity or or um kind
of investment case for you
so you hear the word last mile all the
time last smile last these really are
the last mile in fact these are the last
quarter mile when you think about these
being built in the 70s 80s 90s they have
thousands of homes within a mile of
their radius they have mature
infrastructure they have police forces
and they have fire systems and they have
everything you would need
all around them already number one
number two
the tenants that these buildings uh the
tenants in these buildings they're not
necessarily amazons these are the
companies that provide the material for
these cities to grow these are the
cities that provide the
warehouse space for medical providers to
hold medical
equipment these are the these are the
tenants that are often contractors doing
the work on the buildings and the roads
and the streets and everything that you
can think of in a society i mean we're
so
in 2022 all we want to talk about is the
internet the internet the internet and
while the internet's a big thing
most of your life is actually
denominated by the physical world around
you the studio that you're sitting in
the materials that you're using the food
that you eat the health care that you
get and so when i think about class b
industrial a lot of these businesses
that occupy these properties are the
true american businesses that keep
america running yeah it's fantastic to
kind of hear it articulated that way
when you start to think about
investing in these assets uh i think
what makes you all so special is you've
really built a machine take us back to
when you started for and kind of what
was the initial uh starting point and
then how did you actually like
tactically build this into such a
machine where now you can scale so
aggressively
yeah
i think something that's been important
to me is um i wanted to build a business
that could survive me and that meant
there had to be a machine in place that
if i fell over tomorrow and never came
back to earth there was something that
that would survive me
and um so what was important to me
really early on i had a mentor tell me
and this is the case for any business is
your job should be to make yourself less
and less relevant to the business or
you're not really building a business
that has enterprise value and durable
value you're building a business that
really revolves around you which isn't a
bad thing people make a lot of money
building businesses around themselves
but i didn't want that i wanted
something that when i was out doing
whatever i'm doing there was something
working and so
i think it first started as a mental
decision that that's what i'm going to
do i don't think a lot of people even
get there but once you get there you
start thinking about your day-to-day
business as how do i do things that make
myself less valuable to the business
it's not that i'm not valuable to the
business but i truly could fall over
tomorrow and never come back and deals
would still get done at fort
and then really starting to look at
businesses that have done it incredibly
well i think one of the things that if i
had a strength is and i i would
encourage more people to do this is look
at companies that have already done what
you want to do and then trying to
emulate them and do the things you know
their best practices everybody's
different every culture is different but
there's a lot of blueprints out there
because real estate is an old industry
it's the largest
industry in the world like you said
you know you don't have to look hard to
find companies that have done this so my
goal was how do i build a company that
can find deals underwrite deals buy
deals manage deals
lease deals everything without me being
involved in any one of those things and
that really became uh the core focus of
mine and i
eventually hired a ceo so i'm now the
founder executive chairman i have people
that run every one of those things i
just mentioned leasing acquisitions
financing kind of you name it and the
the biggest thing is they're all
incentivized to do their job do it well
do it with the team and keep the company
growing and you know our friend charlie
munger says or maybe it's warren show me
the incentives i'll show you the outcome
and that's really been my entire focus
over the last five years is replacing
myself and building a machine that could
live on beyond me so when you think
about this um and you get started i
think it's a really important point of
like hey i want to build a machine that
survives me right i think that that's
like a great call out uh when you get
started is it just like hey we go do one
deal and you are basically 100 of the
team and over time you just organically
grow or is it something where in order
to do this successfully you actually
raise outside capital uh from like an
equity standpoint you say okay to do
this correctly you have to start with
the team and almost uh lessen the
dependence on you on day one like how
did you think about kind of where you
get started with how dependent the
business is on you and then the
transition to where you are now where
it's basically not dependent on you at
all
yeah
so as i recall you worked at a hedge
fund am i right or a big financial firm
so
um you'll relate to this a lot of people
start in the deal business or the
investment business because they're good
at investing in something
but being really good at investing in
crypto does not make you good at
building an organization that has an hr
department and an accounting department
and all of these people they're actually
two completely different things
and very few people actually realize
that so i'll now speak about real estate
but you can relate this to almost any
investment uh type of firm no matter
what you're doing in investing
most people get in they're really good
at doing deals they start
they do three or four deals maybe they
hire an assistant and a couple wingmen
to kind of help them do deals but the
key thing here is the person leading the
charge is really a deal person they're
great at investing in real estate
they're great at finding deals
then all of a sudden they look up one
day and they're like oh man we have five
deals all of my time is consumed now
managing these deals managing the few
people that i have we don't really have
a culture we have no processes we're
just deal people
that is where most people stall out
or they don't really know that they're
trying to build a company so they stay
that way forever they buy a deal they
sell a deal there's an inflection point
that happens when you go
i don't want to be just a deal person i
want to build a deal company and the
backbones of any company pomp are the
same in a lot of companies you have an
accounting department a finance
department an hr department all the
things that are like i don't want to say
the boring parts of the business but
they're the administrative parts of a
business that make businesses run and in
fact they become the largest part of the
business
so my point in saying all this is there
comes a a fork in the road where you say
do i just want to be this kind of deal
shop with a few people we don't really
have a ton of processes we're just doing
deals and if i go away tomorrow the
whole deal goes the whole business goes
away
or do i want to build a company that
does deals
and making that distinction is a
critical juncture in the road not a lot
of people do it um
and that requires hiring a person or
partnering with a person like my who's
now my ceo
all he worked on for six years is
actually building a company and we just
so happened to be buying a bunch of real
estate but there was a conscious
decision
we're going to get really good at doing
deals but we're going to build a company